almost
every time she goes out primrose deals
with
ignorant comments about her disability
but some incidents have been far more
sinister
she asked us to hide her identity
what's the worst thing that's happened
to you i
think it was the man who
pinned my wheelchair he came up and put
his hand
over my wheelchair controls
um and had another hand in his trousers
pleasuring himself whilst asking if he
could um
care for me it was in invasive
and dehumanizing and it just
it makes you feel like one inch tall
the problem is escalating in england and
wales according to official statistics
the latest figures suggest that sexual
violence against
disabled women has more than doubled in
the last six
years and one campaign group claims that
not one of those cases
has reached the courts victims
want better training for police officers
to improve
conviction rates what i've found is when
speaking with survivors
they'll say things to me like well the
police didn't believe
that i could have been assaulted because
they sort of thought well
who would want to hurt a disabled person
or they thought well
disabled people aren't having sex so
there's very much this portrayal of
disabled people as being
asexual or desexualized those involved
in training
police officers say the conduct does not
follow
guidelines what our training makes very
clear is that you cannot have
um the diminishing or the demeaning of
what the allegation is the alligator
somebody comes to a police station
or calls the police and makes an
allegation of sexual assault this is a
serious matter
to be believed at the point of reporting
and then investigate it fully
there is a new victims code which
enhances the rights of disabled people
and extra government funding to support
survivors from marginalized communities
but primrose fears there'll be no real
change
until those with disabilities are taken
seriously
lisa dowd sky news
well in response a cps spokesperson said
we are working closely with victim
services to improve
how we communicate with victims to help
them understand and
support them through the process our
prosecutors also undergo trauma training
to ensure that they are able to
evaluate evidence while taking into
consideration how trauma can impact
on memory behavior and demeanor